[Music]
[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone
hi Rob hi Mike I'm Mike and Rob as you
can see we're playing far cry 5 we can't
there's some stuff we can't show I think
review embargo I don't know if we're
public about that it's next week so
hopefully wasn't embargoed but yeah
we're gonna be showing a little bit of
beginning of the game you and I've been
playing it kind of all week Jean Luc's
I'm playing it ed in Australia we've all
been playing it it's pretty fun man it's
very dumb fun it's dumb fun in the most
s Far Cry video Far Cry game ever yeah
yeah right it's it it's Far Cry but it
feels kind of finest in a way but the
open worlds very good yeah you'll notice
right away much like Assassin's Creed
origins did instead of a mini map they
put like the Skyrim compass up there at
the top right right even if you look at
your like map musics good musics great
that's a topographical thing shows like
landmarks and everything yeah so just
for people who you know we're not gonna
spoil anything too drastic this is after
like kind of the intro we're kind of
still in tutorial waters here but once
we get off this like island is where the
game actually opens up and we won't be
spoiling anything drastic at all we're
just gonna kind of mess around and show
you what kind of like honestly the the
open-world sandbox is all about because
it's it's fun for context yeah a
religious fanatical cult has taken over
a valley a fictitious valley Hoke County
and Montana and basically this dude
Dutch just told you to start liberating
this island right here it's in the very
center of the map by pretty much
upsetting the cult balance and gathering
followers of your own recruit people of
your own this is not new to the series
but its new recently so not yet actually
if you played Far Cry 2 and you really
like the kind of procedural a or not
procedural the characters that you
developed over time relationships with
that is in here in the specialist of
which there are nine
if you want to protect yourself I think
there's a prepper stash near the
boathouse
yeah want to talk about that in a second
but so actually we could talk about guns
for hire in a lot but then there are
guns for hire and you they're just
people you bring on missions with you
and I'm the AI is really dumb sometimes
they they fluctuate between very good so
yeah I have a specialist grace unlock
the sniper who you might have seen in
gameplay trailers and then you can get
Nick the pilot who comes in to us
through like air support so don't you
simple if you're gonna try to be
stealthy you can still just bomb the
check it out yeah but uh I have this
character that I really love that wasn't
scripted he's just this procedural
character that I rescued and I brought
him with me on most missions there's
boomer the dog the dog could anyway
Barry I'm sure people have seen the bear
you me and John Luke like these you see
the diamond highlighted on the map so
you could turn that off if you want it
to ya there's you know there are some
things you may want to turn off because
I'll you know one of the things that we
keep talking about is how this game
feels very heavy-handed in like
exploration where you you're not really
resorting to a map and doing checklist
type stuff you're kind of making your
own discoveries and and really honestly
playing the way you want in an open
world and oftentimes getting distracted
with something else that yeah it's you
know in the distance not on your
mini-map but like here shovel tell me
about these preference dashes that your
trapper stashes let's do that
prepper stashes have been awesome yeah
so I think I think we all can kind of
agree that sometimes an ubisoft
open-world game can get a little like
repetitive right maybe formulaic right
you lahic where it's like oh you're
doing this between this again again it's
kind of the same routine but these
prepper stashes are more or less like
vaults or like very unique and I want to
say like more handcrafted side quests
that they're that that end in a bunch of
money which obviously is valuable and
maybe a weapon or new vehicle
they're also perk magazines oh so tell
people how you in this game I guess
while you're doing that I can explain it
in this game whereas in previous games
you just accrue experience to unlock
abilities and this
you complete challenges much like
they're pretty self-explanatory get ten
death hand gun kills that'll give you
one part and then you get thirty handgun
goes out of you next we could show the
screen in a little bit you want to why
not so there's five different trees but
you can pretty much unlock everything
it's not like funneling you into one
tree so here you go yeah so some of the
ones you can get right up front is the
parachute down one and then that will
unlock the wingsuit which is like for
Far Cry veterans those are really useful
and fun the grapple hook from Far Cry
playing so that's what's cool too like
in Ubisoft fashion they've slowly
introduced features throughout the games
so now you have like the Assassin's
Creed origin compass and now you have
the Far Cry 4 primal traveling life this
is the first thing I did oh I do but
it's actually works out really well
I'm confused my couldn't pull out don't
I have to like hit this you got drained
the water first
oh that's why I don't remember this
so it so right now this is just like a
tutorial izing the prepper stashes first
so apparently there's there's a power
nearby on that objective marker yeah and
you can turn I turn those off I mean the
game gets its I'm surprised I like them
without it I mean it definitely I don't
I like the game a lot because of its
discoverability um an immersiveness yeah
yeah yeah but I'm obviously like with
far cry with far cry 2 but really far
cry 3 and and every game sends like
watchdogs to Assassin's Creed origins
Assassin's Creed syndicate even to an
extent Ubisoft has tried to make those
anecdote factory games they call them
which is just like just sound overly
academic just like that emergent game
probably stuff felt like it just
randomly happens like you'll all be
aiming at a guy from a distance at an
outpost and I'll shoot an arrow miss him
but I'll hit a cage and only a cougar on
everything that happened last night yeah
I screwed myself over heard yesterday
not last night that's it's it's funny
man like I feel like I can get like at
the most five minutes in without maybe
like laughing at something or it's like
yeah bear will come out at you like
you're focused on something else and
then if bear will come out of the woods
you said you were playing I was I saw
your gameplay you were playing and you
one of your guns for hire was getting
mauled by a bear yeah he's like what was
he saying so we were cross I had I got
the perks that allows you to have two
guns for hire at once which is awesome I
recommend you go for that I had grace
the sniper and yeah Luke Smith the dude
I got the beginning
he's not a real character he's just one
of those procedural dudes that I had
grown accustomed to
oh yeah he's he's swimming out of the
river in this black bear is just like
pounding his face and then in his
infinite wisdom Luke when something's
coming I just know something is rending
your face right now and look up so from
now on the prepper step the prepper
stash is we'll just kind of randomly
you'll talk to people once you liberate
cult POW posts right if you played Far
Cry before you know how they'll come up
but they're usually really good
environmental puzzles I don't wanna
spoil any of them but um some of there's
one that we I keep talking about that
I've told you like the side quest in
this game are very good you can come
across them at any point like maybe
you'll find someone to talk to and
they'll tell you about it or you'll find
a note or you'll just see something in
the environment that doesn't make sense
and then you'll figure out why it's very
good but um yeah for those bubble guts
on YouTube I'm just saying played one
Far Cry played them all say it ain't so
um this is definitely a Far Cry game but
I think it's it's I don't know how much
review ish I haven't played the whole
game I'm not yet doing it but so far
it's my favorite Far Cry game which is
saying a lot because Far Cry 2 is one of
my favorite games I think John Luke in
that respect could also relate but I
mean Rob you played three four primal
you played a lot of them all of yeah
yeah and you know it's funny is like
even with four especially primal
unfortunately uh I just kind of fell off
because what felt to be so repetitive
it's like okay I've done this again
you're not having like unique
experiences and again it's like this
open world aspect of like not there's no
hand-holding there's no again like your
map is like for yours and yours only
like you you you you as you were saying
like with the previs - it's like you
talked to someone and then that opens up
so like you kind of start accumulating
all these quests because you have talked
to people and I it's nice to have a
break and be like okay that's enough I'm
going to now get my chores done right
and then and then maybe I'll talk to
more people it's not overwhelming it's
not like you should look at a map and
you go oh cool that's you know
hundred hours yeah like it's you're more
in the moment and that's just that's
what's been keeping me going like oh I
can't wait to like discover something
like for myself yeah it doesn't feel as
cookie-cutter at one point so you do
climb one tower and then they kind of
it's self-aware joke
the dude over the radio says don't worry
I'm not gonna make you do this again
they're just like obviously like I think
peak tower climbing in the three and
four and primal to some extent we're
like very widely criticized not many
people like doing that I don't have as
much problem the towers a lot of people
but um yeah they're not there's one in
this and they'll say like it's a
self-aware joke about not have you have
it anymore yeah see right here I mean
there's as where the other park rides
there's a drug aspect to this yeah I
love dynamite I love it anyway when
you're cooking it you can see if you're
holding our one you can see the fuse
this is your influence and on the island
later on you get three regions each
based around one family member of the
seed family the evil family we're
playing a ps4
crow yes and I have to get four at home
vanilla ps4 and it still looks awesome
yeah looks really good
I've run into some bugs not like so like
it's it's almost like Skyrim mish not
the Skyrim level of bugs not that bad
but in the way that you kind of ignore
those because it doesn't really it
doesn't break the game in any way but
there will be some points where like
John Luke and I were playing or watch he
was watching me all of a sudden a dude
would just warp out of nowhere the
spawns are sometimes kind of weird but
yeah it's it does look really good
mm-hmm and yeah obviously it's Montana
like coniferous forest kind of hilly
American Midwest so to speak it's my
favorite setting so far and maybe
because I kind of grew up upstate New
York is kind of like this in general but
I really like this yeah I mean I when I
was growing up I like you see you the
noise she just made that was just so
video game II just like killing this
person it's like yeah I kind of grew up
in Montana
wait you rubbin Montana no I didn't say
that
I didn't mean to say that what I meant
to say is I visited Montana and so it's
like it's it's cool to like I had some
like flashbacks like oh [ __ ] this is
very reminiscent oh there's only one
small part of the map for those asking
obviously they come this is still kind
of a tutorial area like you're on an
island in the middle so if you I don't
know if though if you zoom out you won't
let me gotcha so you're kind of being
introduced the core it's not showing you
how you liberate the areas and then I'll
open up in a sec because this always
Luke Smithers named different for you
here Dave Smith so mine what mine was
Luke really yeah so now he's a gun for
hire so I meant pulling open the roster
page sure and show them so now he's one
of the three slots and he guns for hire
which are just procedural random people
that you see total kills once he gets
enough kills hello and
that first skill I don't know it'll be
like they'll fetch weapons for you
essentially or no they'll gather ammo
for you but um you can kind of command
them where to go or to follow you but
you can rotate them out whenever you
want where I have you can have a max of
3 yeah but the specialists are actual
characters like the dog the bear the
cougar the sniper the air support and
like yeah and obviously there are perks
or the perks that's weird
so that's what I was I actually so b-boy
maestro perks for now you're gonna I
think he finished the we just were
looking at oh yeah but yeah like certain
companions like boomer right is the dog
he can spot enemies and animals and then
there's like the bear or but the bear
will just be like a major distraction
like and have you know you're special
are you yeah yeah it's boomer the dog is
kind of like a D dog yeah yeah totally
or the Panther from Far Cry primal kind
of did that similar so I hope so for a
while turned off the enemy's silhouettes
cuz I didn't really like that what how
do you do that I wonder right now yeah
go to I didn't know which one it was
interface go down two icons second one
enemy tag icons turn are you sure but
then it just removes I would like to
have the diamonds yeah I think that's
correct that they're part and parcel
fare but I don't like seeing like a
hologram of someone behind a wall right
I know I wish you could just do the I
wish you could just tag them as well and
then what are not worried is because
you're kinda becomes not useless without
those but he is not he is less powerful
but you don't have him yet bark look at
some all you accuse me he'll tell you
someone's around use won't know we're
there yeah that's fair people are asking
if there are different guns yeah they're
different guns here's one no sorry
people asking if there are different
guns than we're in three and four
yeah there's a bunch they really lean
into the what do you want to say like
the kind of guns you might expect like
MIT like a rural American people to have
like there's but then there's also the
call
yeah I love these procedural generated
but it's all like private militia
weapons so like it's stuff that you
could buy it like like a Walmart Dave I
told you to do something so you start
off with the basic like a Saul rifle
kind of it it's yeah they're the guns
you could like buy it like an actual
like but you could buy if you wanted to
but then you start getting crazier [ __ ]
oh you get crazier [ __ ] for sure I for
one am a big fan of arrow in the corners
and what in the corners what a weird
inside joke the same inside the angelo
jeremy trees vickers I for one I'm a fan
of the corners you know what I've been
good for breakfast so you see your
influence going up on this island yeah
yeah like guns at Bass Pro or Cabela's
at first at least like it makes it's
cool because like a lot of the people in
this area are survivalist as well or
prep Doomsday Preppers so they have
bunkers that's why you saw that one yeah
these setting makes a lot of sense which
is why I really I didn't the cults been
creeping around the island for weeks I
didn't really super like the old Rangers
are crying well I like [ __ ] a fireman
but I I thought it made good use of its
setting yeah that's that's very high
that's just another game I tripped it
off yeah you know I'm a trans man out
here
yeah for those asking this is ps4 Pro is
this on the ultra settings or whatever
yeah yeah it's archived so oh also um I
guess you'll see soon what did he tell
we gotta go liberate the outpost so you
are still liberating called outpost yeah
it's kind of a mounting right yeah I
think I feel like the cult outposts are
the the biggest head honchos of the law
right yeah like that's kind of you you
liberate an outpost and that's where you
really open up a bunch of side quests
from other NPCs and stuff the framerate
stuttering no no they're just asking
what it is is it it runs it is it 60 now
that's a good question
I have a hard time telling sometimes I
want to say I want to say 60 but I don't
want to spoil it but you can there's fog
everywhere right now there's a really
cool moment when you do climb the one
tower in the game and I I thought for a
while like the draw distance in this
game sucks but then the fog clears and
you're like oh sure there's a lot to do
okay let me look that up actually that's
a fair question it's been it's been
pretty solid at least for the most part
there will be some stutters like I feel
like when you enter a like area
sometimes it'll like chug but yeah
there's been a little bit of that not
like it's not drastic you're mental yeah
PEGI 13
not seeing it we have that reviewer
guide that we could consult allow it sir
Dave get him somebody said it was this
is an open world call of duty
there's a lot more depth to the way the
systems interact I mean I'm sure they
might have Dave davydov Dave did like a
like a no-look one-shot
I love the AI it's funny later cuz like
last the last few games I feel like it's
it's fun it's like they've owned up to
like the bugginess and the just the dumb
it's just dumb it's fun dumb and I feel
like they really kind of owned it here
Eddie Tran who is reviewing the game
told me the funniest thing he said that
one of the vents were higher had an RPG
and he asked her to kill a target and
she goes to a phone pole and just
they're just so dumb showing you the
clip I have I was with grace the sniper
and Luke Smith my boy and I this dude
was going by on a jet ski on the river
and I ordered her to kill him and you
see her laser sight like following him
and I was like guys she was shoot and
then I hear her shoot was like I think
she missed and all of a sudden the dude
just like slowly peeled off his jet ski
and yeah that's that last thing people
are getting mad at IGN is showing the
entire opening cutscene yeah I mean that
was a John Luke's call to skip that
actually he was saying yeah there's a
little bit of a spoiler oh well yeah
there's an embargo know there's an
embargo for sure but yeah but honestly
there's no you're not supposed to
there's like one line you're not
supposed to show so it would be just far
easier like I don't know it's like I'm I
don't even need to spoil it obviously
but it's like a one moment that's kind
of hard to predict so it's like screw it
yeah there's no point of showing the
whole entire cutscene like honestly you
you know people are curious about this
game like I'm more willing to show like
what like you know the basis of the
gameplay is right just messing around
and like having fun
yeah for sure I think that's what people
would rather watch anyway um so for
those just joining I had mention this
earlier this is uh how about I've played
like maybe 10 hours of the game so far
are you you more than me I think maybe a
little more but not but this is the one
tower I've climbed and they will all
turn up the volume we can hear the joke
I'm pretty good I've climbed one other
tower I climbed another one but not to
reveal activities just to wingsuit off
and zipline it but in it's funny like
like you're climbing I swear like
everything you're kind of doing is feel
it feels unique and not repetitive so
like I climbed a tower for a different
reason and something else happened tops
of power did he already say it
he totally did I said okay so he said
like don't worry I'm not gonna make you
do this again it's just a joke
referencing the radio towers are written
like how did Dave get up there if you're
quick the review is coming next week
Monday I would say there were there will
be a review in progress and I think
right yeah we'll have because we want
testing on online services there's like
arcade which is like ice like a even
further like sandbox kind of customize
your own fun levels and stuff okay
here's the here it is
so these are all siblings the villains
Joseph yeah John is the other one well I
want to open up the chat for a vote
which way to go I don't know do you just
have one that you think might be better
so I went Southwest to go to John I
think you did as well I did as well but
like yeah you you're you're pretty free
to do whatever you want I say we get a
plane here okay do we want to get boomer
gets to either cheeseburger the bear
boomer or
what's the what's the Cougars name yeah
so what we'll have chat tell us which
one so what what companion should we get
a bear a cougar or a dog you guys you
guys vote and they are all pretty
freaking awesome yes so you see these
big side missions with the specialists
on it that's how you unlock though that
person's support so Nick arrives the air
support grace is awesome I like her a
lot she is like if in terms of gameplay
she's like the quiet of Far Cry 5 mm-hmm
peaches is the Cougar
bear huh people are going for the bear
okay cheeseburger yeah let's do it
I for one I'm a fan of the Krueger but
where is the bear the Bears
Oh way up there oh so you got him
already I'm in your game no oh you have
a you have a lot more specialists
alright let's go let's do the bear okay
all right thank you chat sorry for the
people who wanted a boomer or peaches I
do I do want to show some flying cuz
flying is flying planes and this is
awesome and I'd actually say it's better
than the helicopters I don't I'm not a
big fan of the helicopters in this game
they're like kind of tough to control
the planes flying is very simplified in
a good way though it's in a great way
like fluid and elegant like there are
just like a couple fundamentals I feel
like you have to have when flying a
plane in a video game is one is like
manual roll I can't roll my plane and
you're forcing me to like have just like
the horizon as a plane and only stick to
that then I'm not having fun you see the
fog start to clear and the rest them not
the rest of the map but much more of it
Far Cry arcade is that even live now or
we like that it's live we can do it
later okay that's definitely the plan we
are all sinners we could probably skip
this I can't okay gotcha me so this is
brother so they kind of lead you to go
to him first right with this yeah you
don't have to you kind of don't think
but I think his area has like a lot of
the variety of the game you know what I
mean like it's got like the basis like
the plane and like your dog a pretty
solid gun-for-hire
who's this gerald jared leto looking
dude be maestro who's Jared oh this guy
yeah I guess I guess I see that so John
is kind of in charge of recruitment and
like conversion for the cult yeah I wish
police officer
Gabriela says I say the elephant there
ain't no elephants in Montana you're
silly
yeah for those people saying only two
people said bear where we have three
chats up GameSpot YouTube and twitch a
new pair was the winter thing was it
though people got to bear first let's
just play the game and see what happens
but we'll try to do the bear I don't see
I'm a big stealth guy okay but you don't
know it up to the chat if you're not
gonna go about I'm not dissing the chat
I apologize I'm just I just wish it
wasn't a bear but we're totally did
we're totally doing the bear look the
Cougar is sick the Cougar does like
silent takedowns or like smoke to blunt
it does do sound it wouldn't be that far
off from the sky office tower and stop
these dumb jokes it's taking me forever
to go oh use the zip line what are you
doing oh that's totally how I did the
first time
oh I see so he really does yeah so it
leads you at least to the first kind of
outpost area and then from there that's
definitely where you like well hello
oh is this a supply truck blow up like
the convoy trucks yeah oh you'll see
these driving around and they always
what those are I blow those up all the
time they have dope ass stuff body armor
for body armor
arrows toilet paper give the bow the
boat was in that first Preppers - why
didn't you didn't get it
seriously it was yeah that's where I got
mine
sorry I know it's not alright because I
really want that bow dammit
can we go back and get it yeah let's not
tarry too much to do
where was yeah the silver like nearby
right the boathouse was the power the
boathouse no no but it was right there
right no it was in the bunker that you
drained yeah but it was like right by
the boathouse I believe so so that is
this way fin 76 and twitch said it's
Friday I thought it was Thursday good
news everyone
that is good news I thought it was
fighting the other way around I thought
it was Monday I thought it was Thursday
then it's Friday did you see week for
those yeah for those watching live we
got some cool stuff coming at GDC we
talked to Brendan green player unknown
yesterday about pub G in the future of
the game we talked to yen's mattis the
creative director of Wolfenstein 2 and
we're just gonna do like a post-mortem
on that game well we already did we're
gonna publish it sometime next week
hopefully mhm and today we have yoga
taro and terrace on the producer from
Platinum coming to talk it's like near
automatons one-year anniversary so
Michael will be it's on the wall I
believe in the back room Michael yeah
got some stuff in here doing a
commentary thing with him yeah well it's
gonna be fun
where is this bow you're talking okay it
was in here funny I promise it was on
that the wall right there did you blow
something up in here on access no it
didn't that sorry weird
oh it says
money so yeah money big deal in this
game do you uh you use it to buy things
do you kind of mean this game is very
function you get off this island this
game once you get to the mainland so to
speak the I would do I said the roads
are pretty dangerous
there are supply vans there are prisoner
vans that you can liberate to get more
people there are just convoys and there
are Jesse's jetski yeah
but also like if you stick to the
wilderness it's obviously more likely to
get attacked by now
I had me do this one more time we're
going to the bear
which I had a son yeah Nicholas Espinoza
Ben and gentleman will be screaming
monster hunter later on today around - I
believe we postponed it just because the
embargo for this lip they attend money
you also buy cool planes and vehicles
they're special they have like you know
mount gun mounts and bombs and rockets
and stuff I think I think one of the
game how well it tells you but like when
the best ways to make money is like
hunting right there's like perks that
let you like double the amount or double
the return of like bear skins and stuff
so you can gain that green quickly
[Music]
so this is going toward its brother's
name
Jacob I always like now you see like the
call guys and there's just like two of
them just like grab each other what are
they actually doing come on let's hit
the water come on now hold on tack they
they really do save God weird stuff they
do it's great for cruising cruising your
sac no that's an action happening over
here go check out okay
there's a car - hey fellas meat wagon
nice
oh my god you cooked that for a while
too long yeah
some behind me there's some time oh
great oh it's worth mentioning this game
can be kind of tough yeah this game hard
oh great a spare screw this was a bear
there right by the truck
where'd he go oh it's a heavy armored
dude that's why you like I'm going to
die I don't have nearly enough yeah you
should get out of here
later at Melanie's thank you
where's the ball crate
[Music]
like the driving is better than this
game - have you done ah have you done
the have you used like the auto drive
and then like shoot it's pretty freakin
awesome I have shot you know I forgot to
use the auto driver I don't is there a
bridge isn't going all that well yeah
okay I'm better on foot
what is this red yeah Rob let's let's
let's get out let's get to the bear or
something now what do you well know just
told me to go yeah but it's screwed up I
don't know what you're doing with this
tree well there wasn't any roads yeah
true but where we're going we don't know
we don't need roads great what we got
here antlers
sick yeah where's this little hunting
stand some arrows tied
what does that noise with this all wolf
be against I forgot the [ __ ] Jacob
recruits these wolves fired wide is that
uh animal you can release now oh yeah
there's a wolf
[ __ ] he's an armored dude isn't he
oh yes so they can go down who's your
daddy he doesn't have a collar oh yeah
so he's one of Jacob's yeah put your dog
on a leash my good joke
I saw I love dogs last night national
puppy day and you just kill the wolf Hey
oh you're dead oh yeah so my hunting and
this is mainly for money just sell the
pelts and right feathers and stuff
Cougars have some good return yeah
helpful tip what's up here what's up
here I'm hoping for a nice weapon I want
a bow and arrow looks like I have a lot
of arrows we met KITT there's a bow
honey perks yet to spend nope so like
you really want I feel like early on
like that wasn't the first thing I
wanted was to have another weapon slot
where's that two to the right a gun in
the holster
yeah cost eight eight well we definitely
go bow over Saul rifle apparently I
agree I can pick it up yeah what's this
this is ridiculous yeah this should be
working there you go okey-dokey
artichokey let's get that bear huh
uh yeah Leon FC 1016 for those who
joined we kind of we explained a little
bit earlier but perks in this game are
unlocked by completing challenges you
saw those available pork points there's
really despite the fact that there were
five different tracks you don't have to
stick to one obviously you can probably
unlock all of them but you essentially
complete challenges to
like get 10 handgun kills or yeah I
guess you show so these right here you
get these and you get it'll tell you how
many poor points you'll get for doing
that yeah hundred people you get three
that's a lot or you stick to handguns
you get one so you just kind of check
these off it's it's a exponential so
each time you go up you probably you get
more everybody well not each time
there's I'm sure that it max but you can
also get perk magazines kind of like
fallout and those will give you just
ability points to spend yeah right and
you'll find those and like the prepper
stashes as you saw earlier yeah you can
to this in general areas once you get
you can fish once you get a fishing rod
and yeah there's no more of that
skinning animation on the animals
thankfully because that got really
annoying after a while
oh that was San Jose Brian Schubert
swimming upstream I haven't run into the
microtransactions yet why he'd well I
can show them yeah oh for the silver
bars right yeah oh I have to be in a
shop yeah we can show them one good
thing yeah it's I don't know it's just
just alternate currency yeah I don't see
the point to it I don't know I don't
understand who would spend money to do
such but is there anything in this cabin
down should I get an arrow kill oh you
can go in a lot of the buildings in this
but there are those most buildings I
would I would say like most buildings
you can go into not this one ooh a
shotgun
now I'm good baby actually those tickets
truck
hee ha
you like my gloves yeah you always go
with those something you'd like those
yeah they have bones on it's like my
hands are falling off or something
Nikolai yes off apology strike what's
your last name
we are playing this Ubisoft was kind
enough to give us a few codes for review
and preview purposes today we can you
can't like share review thoughts I mean
too much I guess but uh what what did I
hit something what what happened
I blacked out it's funny cuz people are
just asking if you can trunk driving
this it's the same person I think one of
your friends is in the chat Rob Vicki do
you know a guy named Eric
yeah it's Eric that's my boy yeah he
said it's my baby boy Rob he looks so
good but he wishes the video of us was
the big Street he's just playing alright
well I think we got this bear pretty
soon yeah this is a ps4 or pro he looks
really good on just original ps4 well
your call original vanilla yeah I guess
so
what the [ __ ] okay I've not done this
mission really for the record no oh so
there's a grapple hook right there once
you get that grapple hook yeah the
driving feels good driving I would say
is is better than four yeah definitely
wasn't there weren't there wasn't any
driving in Primal right if you were on a
limits oh this is gonna be awesome
you are meet what's up oh it worked out
what what that was your body that was my
outer body yeah they do know I'm here
huh
well bow and arrow is not gonna be you
really just went I shot you really just
went for it
[Applause]
there's a machine gun hitting you I
think hi how are you okay alright so
stealthy you're going solo that's what
it looks like when you die and these
menus are great yeah the loading screens
are really good they're pretty dope look
at that wolf thank you quazy I could be
called just standard ps4 not vanilla I
guess that's a standard standard it's
pretty good that's that's standard I
like that better
vanilla everybody's just like it's fine
hope you find Eric get out of here okay
so alright yeah let's let's let's get
let's get tactical let's a weird dogs
pop-up oh that's cool if it's just
animals and stuff because we turned off
icons on enemies I want to be an enemy
because in Jos Jacobs region the wolves
are like right there like trained
mutilated can I make a suggestion
sure try bud dude get this dude first I
get spotted by who though obviously
you'll be spotted he's like he's by
himself
you got the bow and arrow that's what I
meant take a bow and arrow
oh not zipline down no sure good night
oh [ __ ] they fall that's dude I don't
think this guy needs to take a freaking
battery that headshot you for that yeah
he's got the he's a Colt VIP you get
extra this guy you get extra yeah yeah
yeah sure shot bone arrow is so good
it's so good all right who else we got
here so you want to go for the alarms
right so there's two alarms here oh [ __ ]
they really it's not body they don't
know where you are that we just got good
good good good
so hypothetically if you had grace the
sniper here you could place her on this
cliff to cover you and chill once you
exit stealth she'll just start shooting
at will or you can commander to shoot
certain people I really like having
great feel like this guy saw me yeah
he's coming up we'll bring it on uh yep
oh hey guys there are so many people
coming up this cliff you got dynamite
dynamite boom altough yes please is this
a copy/paste of Ghost Recon uh no it
says way more just random shock that
yeah it's off in midair what a badass
somes behind me huh now it's Phil him
those guys are tough Balam jeez yeah
they're really armored up Bob Jones
it sounded really close you hit him
oh I see what's a sound like a shotgun
or something remote sure I do like in
this game how they pretty much give you
everything it feels like real early on
lights out Oh God he turned into vapor
man but his gun did you see his gun went
flying so turn people away let's watch
it let's see if you do it again Oh doubt
they're mine oh this guy feels the eager
bring your dog up here ps4 Jeremy
swimming pro pro ps4 pro hi pal gesture
yeah oh right in the schnoz oh right in
the SHM is God a shot Thanks
all right this is some ring down here
I'm liking this what are you doing ah oh
there a wingsuit take down a wingsuit
take down oh I guess you'd that pilot
remote explicit temperature oh that
would have been good he's kind of
alright I'm swept in I'm swapping excuse
me it's famous sniper wait oh never mind
I need a better weapon no I don't want
to do this but sure nope oh this is good
this is good it's got a nice little
scope sure
whoa
this is a sniper right no this is just a
semi-auto it's I think it's a rifle with
a Auto rifle with a scope on it yeah you
can craft the med kits as well oh really
just random stuff you find yeah la raza
yeah why won't you die
that's the same guy no you don't ask dog
I know I mean obviously because people
wanna do the bear we had to go to one of
the more difficult areas this is where
the brother this is the brother that
trains everything everybody for the cult
to be like soldiers and then they do do
looks like Conor McGregor and then John
like recruits people solid fox says
hello what have I missed nothing did we
just start him we're starting this for
the first time alright so I guess we'll
get this another shot
go from a different angle maybe I mean I
was doing okay taking these dudes out it
feel like yeah
I love the impact of the bullets in this
game yeah arrows should I
zipline now down there or take out this
guy and try to take out those alarms
that's what's gonna do me over to
prevent them from calling in people yeah
namely that damn helicopter and let me
off yeah go for this shot we Ziggy Ziggy
could not have died any louder
all right there right now should I just
keep doing this mm should I go down get
in and use explosives yeah can you blow
up the alarms yeah you can really yep I
don't know if arrows will do it but yeah
I do that often with handguns and stuff
you could do with handguns I don't know
if you need over motive all right that
works where's the other one
there's a few yeah
use those more literally whoa
yeah let walk next one just kept rolling
do you see him watch it roll down the
hill
Oh it was like he literally was like
that oh I thought that no I thought that
was remote still fantast you're out of
those do you have proximity ones yeah
good lure them in oh you got a cult VIP
boom pretty that's a heavy armor dude oh
oh oh please please use a MEK it oh I
thought you just died me too
oh so you got a perk point can you I
wonder if it's enough to get anything I
have to perk points no sweet well should
I get what will help me in this
situation
maybe the well I can swim faster that'll
be good and hold your breath longer more
handgun in melee weapons I'm gonna wait
none of this is gonna help me pretty ex
just said watching people play games is
just too frustrating why you innamal
it'll you know what live streams are I I
hear you but
Oh Oh the helicopters here great
ooh that actually broken glass
did you get oh he's turning around I
think got him leave just just leave that
sounded really good just just walk away
oh that's not the helicopter
just walk away
yeah maybe need an assault rifle did any
of those guys drop something useful
oh so you're hidden right now
you can get a bigger quiver you know
that
that's it oh come on yeah have you ever
guy I don't know it didn't look like
it's me but you're wrong
I have not played it on PC Jared he's
asking if we know how well optimized it
is no we don't know
this bone arrow sucks yeah I also don't
have any more of it
those dudes drop assault rifles right
holy God
you can make a medkits oh [ __ ] there's
the helicopter
yeah oh they're saving me yeah there's
nothing there for now
perfect Joe map oh machine gun for the
helicopter I think I can spin this round
though all the way I hope yeah where are
you baby
[ __ ] everybody off with this thing oh I
hear you I hear ya ya [ __ ] fell
outside Bailey
Drive Bailey put a piece of [ __ ] man I
could be here all day oh oh they're
coming you're right yeah I'll be waiting
explores the barrel next I know I'd see
that thing wearing it's it's it's just
standing there menacingly
come on come on Oh Oh what nice he's
dead
I like this oh no oh yes god that feels
so good to just waste those guys yeah it
really does
what do you say there's no idea what you
say wait huh
what alright this is the like I just
twitch it
yeah all right I think I could like this
is this this seems manageable
Hockley jinx jinx it oh you got an m6 o
that you know that dude nice minigun on
the go
I love how read in the videogames is
just such an avoidable thing yeah it's
like oh that's really read oh he's up on
your nevermind sorry it was a wall oh my
god
yeah there we go so it's cheeseburger
here yeah [ __ ] yeah we got a bear mall
people now having companions in this
game helps yeah like you you'd like to
think that it's one of the reasons it is
very tough but like I think there's a
when the toughest school see okay check
his pulse
all right guys let's clean up his balls
yeah like I feel like the difficulty
kind of pushes you to always utilize
your companions and stuff like I once
like you know had like boomer and some
other dude and then like took them off
once and like felt immediately difficult
difficult again I was like oh [ __ ] like
once I had that friggin bear all right
so now it's like the side quest to get
cheeseburger it doesn't take too long
always like simply going on how can you
hire oh could you hire Wade when [ __ ]
gunshots on what do I really want this
guy I will say in the dialogue in this
game they did not go for brevity and it
often times I'm just like okay shut up
please
yeah Oh a melee expert I've never hired
one of them
I don't know what would you know pepper
stash quest he is always on the case try
sneaking up on him I dare you I heard
something
I'm just glad to see it out of the hands
training those wolves to cause help and
they've been chipping those crazy wolves
all the way to the old lumber mill keep
an eye on prisoners now we had a bear
here named cheeseburger a bit of a local
celebrity actually had a soft spot for
Chad's barbecue but he got the diabeetus
so we put him on a liquid salmon diet
tried to take third I set him free last
I heard he was causing all sorts of
mayhem someone should go find him
make sure he's all right I will I'll
find him salmon from the pond ahead of
time though
then feed cheeseburger that salmon and
he'll be eating out of the palm of your
hand
Oh someone wanted to see some fishing
well we're gonna go fishing man got some
money to buy a new new what
actually no you need a resistance if I
gone I kind of want a good gun like that
sniper rifles going lost are you know
oh so someone was asking about
microtransactions well that's right here
so you'll see you buy silver bars is the
currency and then the kind of the bottom
right there 200 I don't know the
conversion of silver dollar to real
world but well I don't have enough money
for much oh I could get a pipe
[Music]
so there's customisation you know you
know you can um change the fire range
stuff to you know that really yeah I
know you could you like this scopes and
stuff let's see there oh I see you mean
like yeah yeah that one dude whoa buddy
all right let's take this undercover cop
car that's my car
fine fine take a right to bear arms
clever right well I do like to driving
like the handbrake I feel like there
wasn't a handbrake in far cry 4 as far
as like drifting and sliding it's like
pretty gratifying yeah
[Music]
cupcake Galaxy really wants to see us
plague up arcade mode set it quite a few
times even seen none took someone's
talking whoohoo airplane
well microphone check microtransactions
are not from what I've seen you don't
need to do them now XD kak you don't
they'd speed it up I don't cut him off
before he could tell oh my gosh all my
stuff here's some Wolfskin 170 bucks
just like in real life
sick fishing brings a body piece and
don't we ever need peace in times like
these he would be a fool not to take
advantage of the fishing around these
parts that's the saying a moment just
look how my car is there
that's yours behind the tree yes I
arrived that was great driving most
people don't stop before they act not
every problem
okay so that's what I'm talking about
the guy Allah he could have said I know
half that cross he's still talking how
do you fish much it's it's fun I don't
know much about fishing but it feels
like I am so then we got to do is always
in making me read I have to read how to
fish no no no you're just standing on
top of the note I just keep tapping l2
and it works really well see ya
oh there it is there's the prompts so
you got a real it back just keep ever
ever so slightly you'll you'll see the
movement other fish you'll see the
ripples in the water and that's what the
dialogue is like audiotapes you don't
have to stand there for most of them
they just talk too much
oh-oh-oh-oh
you have to keep doing that five fishing
is yeah there you go yes
now l2 and the right stick oh come on
this shape of water what are you gonna
do that fish I'm gonna we're gonna sell
it yeah what do you think I'm gonna do
with it dude come on oh good get that
camera ready
gotcha nook salmon jinwu 14 pounds
I know beautiful
who told you that who told you that
that's suspicious hey yeah we see a bear
outside all right let's get in my car
oh wait
I feel like walking people asking if you
could fish with dynamite or the Botero
I don't think so them I wouldn't be
surprised I feel like I feel like this
game I feel like they thought of that
probably man I'd really want to fly this
is this would take some time I have to
like go up there I did this once you
don't have to parachute do I do not
should be able to get like a cheap ATV
or something right there we go
special delivery
okay let's go get that bear
what's Horne figured it out
should I come
to
look at those mountains
whoo I'm gonna do this
is this a supply truck oh yeah yeah it's
the trucks that you've been blowing up
apparently yeah we can do it's the map
editor why like arcade stuff do we
really is that what people are begging
for that yeah should we do that
yeah maybe after we get the bear sure do
that a little bit then try out the
arcade tom good you come up you have to
come but you come across the arcade at
outposts anyway where'd this one dude is
just playing it and that won't shut up
about it because it's actually in arcade
machines
all right there's like the coasters yeah
like the auto drive is really great
oh hell yeah
[Laughter]
so brutal you see how it's like the dog
was ready to fight like bring it on come
on hit me i watch it feels like this atv
is a little sluggish down there's blood
in your there's it there's a dog ear and
like exhaust
so cheeseburger the Bears nearby yeah
goob I don't know how much we can talk
about a story I've honestly haven't been
paying too much attention to it I've
been kind of well I've been paying
attention when it happens but I like the
beginning a lot I haven't seen how it
unfolds but I've just mainly been
finding my own story in the game through
the guns for hire and then developing
them and rescuing that one no it's good
no and well oh look at that lovely dog
this is always peaceful because when you
die you feel like a jackass he and then
you get to see this wonderful dog and
again kind of McGregor or Deadpool with
a haircut someone said okay
I meant to do that brakes weren't
working so you just smash it up stuff
you should see you guys should see me
when I play by myself cuz I'm just like
a god oh wait
so can you rescue the bear now and have
him fight yeah okay yeah you hear that
what do you say he said one time I saw a
bear swapping this guy's face off did he
survive yeah but he had to get a new
face
oh is the bear there was a cage I feel
like he was over here
wait look to your right there dead
bodies he's got to be around there oh
you're right no this was totally it I
did it all bears are so freaking nuts
yeah you see those videos with us some
guy in a tree and the bear like keeps
climbing up towards them you think no go
away yeah they just climb like a [ __ ]
yeah nothing come fast - uh the brown
bears run fast I think yeah black bears
are the ones that you can you can scare
off that's the best yeah yeah but then
Grizzlies are just like you're supposed
to play dead you're supposed to die it's
how you survive that's how yes that's
how you get away from a bear attack
whatever happens after you die
go get'em bear-alis he just blasted nine
left look at him he's down the road whoa
what was it a rocket
he threw a smoke grenade right into my
dome oh that hurt cheeseburger I don't
think he's there oh yes to help you he
was he was taking this salmon yeah he
was faking it
oh yeah suck that
see sometimes make make maggots
really so you can I have not enabled
hold r1 go left sorry I press l1 no
sorry r1 again
oh okay nice what oregano have you done
this get oregano
oh you don't have it yet that's where
med kits usually are okay I have not
done a really pure and regna what does
it do I don't know that's why I wanted
to know like is it just
there's also liquor like is it just like
you know you're drunk now fun heads-up
trebles coming
leave my bear alone oh hell yeah
no no no no
looks like my driving well is that a
heart armor dude yeah you're right sit
wow dude whole buildings will go up in
flames
yeah where's my bear
I can't command them right now now I
gotta wait for the love that bear right
now there he is there's my boy nice nice
he just screwed up all right
arkaid sure so I did one arcade mission
last night so it's just essentially it
let's it compiles all the outcasts
outpost missions right or am i coming
off you know it to be honest I don't
know it exactly like how to classify
this but it's like a bunch of stuff
understanding like there's PvP there's
editor so you can like make your own
kind of like I want to say just anything
like any kind of like kind of one-off
dumb activity or quests like they're
pretty straightforward like okay here's
a whole bunch I did one last night that
was so dumb and so funny where was
literally just walking around I'm
entering rooms and there's just like
goats and guts goats walking around and
it just ends but I was laughing cuz it
was pretty it was silly so let's see
what one of these would be Stone Ridge
takedown so it's also probably what you
just said so it's like okay here's an
outpost a bounty hunt this looks cool
let's do that
yeah copy galaxy we got you
they were asking them to check out
arcade can we go in the other I've been
on the editor since Far Cry 3 um I don't
even know if we're allowed to show it
are we we could I don't know how
entertaining that would be yeah um
cupcake galaxy maybe will do so I think
I know like jean-luc likes the map
editor I believe Jake does I don't know
about this game I know they liked him
the other games I'm that might not be
the best thing to show on the stream
unfortunately and I should actually
probably double-check that we're allowed
to we are we're let's show it okay
fairly sure
it's musics good
yes
can't we go fishing again shut up Eric
live events live events I don't know
much about to be honest I want to say
they're like I don't know the equivalent
like GTA online like double RP weekend
or something like that like they're just
like challenges every week okay so this
is a bounty hunt I think it's nice
sniper house sounds pretty good for this
let's get up there this is working out
what on earth is happening you're just
hunting down VIPs or something that's
going there bullet drop I feel like
there is but maybe I'm wrong so I don't
know so it's hard to tell with my
targets are as we turned off at HUD
let's see what happens
Oh IGN stream got shut down because they
broke part of the DNA NDA I did not see
that I remember they were showing the
beginning yeah there's an error there's
a point in the beginning you're not just
show do you know what it is I mean
obviously don't it's just it's just like
a story beat it's like it's like it's a
little spoiler here I guess gotcha
what was it I'm sorry I'm blanking out
what was the I con ya enemy tag icon sir
okay so I think maybe that is helpful
for this what I probably can't see him
that's what's always confusing with all
of them let's get in there a lot of new
assets to the map editor see if I can
finish this and we'll take a look
that would worked out
oh yeah you love those throwing knife
yes I guess you're just going for those
VIPs oh that's a good angle just
sneaking away
I hear dogs it's a good time
oh this guy's got a fanfare see I can
stuff my hey pooch so mean I'm not
trying to hit him I'm trying to distract
him
oh those are rocks with other four
grenades I was also wondering why they
weren't blowing up Robbie's a
flamethrower again you're going right up
to his face I can't get into him I can't
get in here uh-oh
dogs blind no he's not
oh my god how can I get
nice I think it's gotta be you isn't it
this was a far cry arcade mission yeah
so I believe these are these are ball
like the idea is that these are all you
know player created user create right no
these aren't I don't believe so
well maybe these are our official well
that's what yeah okay aya Shan clips
this is arcade well there's that I guess
we could show a little bit of map better
okay oh there's an arcade rank
you know what liked it I don't know if
these three stars are all about I joy
dreadfuls and these are the example ones
to get started
gotcha do you know you make your own
levels in this game that dude is so
annoying
there's this NPC who's just rockin
arcade mode that's crazy it's crazy so
do I have to go out in order to do it I
think I do
I'm shop No
go to our K communicate go back to the
right yeah I think I have to go back out
[Music]
fairly sure because I remember seeing a
prompt
did you think you were free hi as you
would hi I'm Jacob seed Havis you
probably heard of me yeah have a seat I
want to show you this knife up close hi
have you ever felt the feel of Cold
Steel and your neck let me show you
hi I'm Jacob nice to meet you
am i just repeating oh yeah so it was
you're okay it was weird that you have
to back out all the way out edit map new
map new map yeah
oh man I was about to be ecstatic if
this was like a interactive menu you
know I can control this chopper but you
can't looks cool though
people are asking if there's like some
wacky stuff you can put in here cold I
mean this is not gonna be very
entertaining uh as I try to figure this
out
yeah well well I just yeah go to uh add
new objects yeah let's see if I can just
add in like a cougar or some woman no
yeah that's you help me an army of bears
me okay and then just fight them still
got thirty seventy seven sixty percent
to go I like where your head's at oh
these bears on top of each other oh
error too many bears in one time hi I'm
with the map better you have too many
bears hi I'm Jacob I'm crazy you're
crazy
that's like what is that game called
Beast battle simulator except you're
facing all the bit and then ya give
yourself like one dude rocket launcher
okay yeah that's that's a yeah fair fair
fair see how long you survive okay it's
got some distance
yeah can you preview check terrain
weapons
not assault I wonder if this is the case
where you have to like earn or unlock
more oh yeah maybe that's what that now
is it's like kind of limited well well
let's give ourselves an AR oh wait oh oh
that has to be a second weapon slot I
don't know the names guide rockets m79
is the like bazooka
okay uh weapon slot here okay cool
so then we'll do whatever okay
cool that that seems pretty good I can
keep going
how about an LMG sure just the rocket
launcher is fine okay on that and put
your like spawn closer to the Bears oh
do i I think you start off with it right
isn't that what I'm doing right now yeah
do it I don't have to like put it down
no I don't think so
okay well let's see if we get this maybe
miss ball rolling fight play yeah oh um
add new object game mode objects the
spawn point well that's how go closer I
want to see what these Bears do and dude
I think this is plenty of distance
alright game mode objects there you go
nice with your back to them alright okay
let's spin it
your F is not pass validation objects
what's not valid an army of bears so
what do you doesn't really say yeah no
it said check validation menu I'll start
um or no go back to subtract try play
again it told you the hologram
validation option located in the menu on
this Splore management publish
- are published manage map
validation boom
[Music]
what we're gonna take a snap y-nough
enemy AI and wave one oh so you need at
least one dude not just bears and and I
gotta take a snapshot yeah so just do
the snapshot now I guess I get oh I
guess it's like the thumbnail for when
people are browsing through it I'll give
my thumbnail pretty self-explanatory
just bear army I'll have to follow her
not an enemy shret she's gonna get so
[ __ ] up yeah
oh I'm so sorry you were its [ __ ] okay
follow her as in cult follower okay cool
she's gonna get real messed up I wonder
if they'll they'll attack her oh yeah
and then it's okay a snapshot okay there
you go this is a way better thumbnail
right here we had it earlier get down
oh it's speed left click okay how do I
look camera height r1 no no lipstick our
one day oh my god so fast
I just wanna yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I had it yeah yeah that works for
me there you go
sure okay you can't there's a silhouette
of your guy okay cool
you should be value now the play yeah
get that launched yeah this loadout we
made sure he's behind you
[Laughter]
first was like well they supposed to do
spawning or what oh so he made it so
that we we win immediately uh maybe you
could maybe you could do the those
wolves that Jacob controls just fight an
army of them she's right there oh no no
how about okay here hear me out
put another AI in front of you so they
don't kill her immediately and you can
do it no move her to be on the opposite
side of you so you can fight the Bears
yeah I mean yeah what know she'll well I
guess it's fine if she doesn't have a
weapon right so I'll just add another a
Iong what her like it's so messed up to
have her in this situation yeah
no no like on the other side of you so
they run toward you fair yeah that's
good Oh camera work that right there is
perfect yeah alright do it
spin it crying yeah there she is
ignore her
[Laughter]
they're just roaming oh they're going
for it there she is
this is awesome you can make some fun
stuff here get the bear just punched her
oh I'm crying alright let's let's go
back to the single-player huh oh yeah I
think I mean I'm like 15 minutes if that
works cool let's do um let's fly a plane
yeah do plane parity and then we can
call it you have the parachute yep I'll
figure it out okay
olena some water oh my god I can't wait
to see like I I really hope that kicks
off you know like I hope that's
something that like I don't know it
reminds me of halo forge although
although like I don't know the halo 4 CH
have bears like maybe maybe that's what
was missing out like I hope I hope
that's something that you you can return
to you know and like check out like
really awesome just dumb things like I
again I did one last night it was so
dumb it was just literally walk through
like a maze but there's just like goats
like blood rooms it was funny
God that was freaking yeah no problem
Brendon and cupcake Alex you know you
were asking to see the matter better
yeah let's get back into it and honestly
like for a map editor like what was that
15 minutes and we were able to do that
like that was quick I feel like even
maybe Forge might be a little I don't
know intimidating like that that felt
pretty uh pretty easy you know cool you
just battled some bears kind of yeah all
right let's find a plane oh there you go
beautiful I like I like the sea planes
yeah me too well do you have any perk
points to spend on the parachute
probably right I think we were able to
yeah don't
so the wingsuit Safin you might be able
get me another week's it's three right
four okay four
having our guns on this one right and
whatever this is always the saddest part
when you have like boom or two and
you're in a plane like they'll keep
chasing you
it's like dog neglect you can add a
thing yeah humans will get in I wish I
wish
cheeseburger would just jump in the
backseat no but is like face out the
window okay so let's take a thick like
an outpost or something peaches is great
I love it all right so I wish so this is
part of it too right like you you don't
you don't really know where outposts are
you have to like talk to people but
maybe we'll find one just some flying do
the flying in this game is really tight
I really enjoy it yeah it's
it makes sense and streamlined I think
it's cream to it
places smash into the river me too but
you can get real low like the but like
when you get a plan with like a turret I
haven't we
you guys did co-op we'll do that next
week Tuesday on launch will do a flow to
a co-op stream but it seems fun like
there's planes with like turrets and
stuff like ball turrets in the back yeah
you can see a monument to Joseph way
ahead of you
yeah on the mountain I will see if we
find anything so like smoke generally
that's an outpost for sure huh actually
I know that is cuz I've died to that
outpost on many of times I like was
doing passes in a plane and like made
like a third approach and they shot me
up and I like crashed into the water at
the dock and there was a dude there like
ready to kill me so I don't wanna do
that
you can if you damaged enemy planes
enough so you're in the other yam the
other area fried part of the you can
damage enemy planes and then go
parachute out and I stifle on the way
down no kiddin I haven't seen that yeah
[Music]
all right let's do something up
I wish this plane had some
what the homes all right should we go
there sure here this huh
oh is that like Yellowstone like like
hot springs they kind of look like it
might be let's figure let's go check it
out all right you know what even better
let's land in it okay it's gonna be
tough I'm pilot I can fly it
I do like to audio like it sound so
rickety you know I mean yeah it sounds
literally like the middle of these wings
just like flapping around reliable old
reliable
diego we already did arcade mode sorry
yeah diego we we showed it for a little
bit we did arcade in the map editor
we're just gonna finish up with some
plain action oh these are totally hot
springs type kill it nice job beautiful
so the park rangers aren't gonna like
that you've landed in a hot spring but
what bothers elephants no it's hot it's
really oh the hot spring is hot that
might be a good place to call it was a
good landing and i got yeah sure sweet
so we can't really like share review
thoughts too much but rob overall i
think we're having fun with the game
right it's it's dumb fun yeah i i'm
really enjoying this game like if i can
say anything yeah again we're not
reviewing it but like at this point
during my play with like far cry 4 even
primal like i would have kind of been
burnout like seeing maybe a little bit
of the repetition but like so far it's
like i'm gonna kick off just like
exploration like right there right like
we saw some hot springs landed
something's going on there yeah i love
it
just random like anecdotes come out of
it's really fun yeah yeah our view up i
review in progress at least will be a
Monday cuz i know there's some online
components that we have added the
reviewer and australia will have to test
out but that'll be up monday will have
some stuff going i know a gentleman who
kept some videos going up today right
like gameplay focus yeah we got some
gameplay we're gonna have like an early
like you know like starter kind of guy d
here's here's things to do when you
first are playing nothing spoilery but
yeah review coming up early next week
yeah but yeah thank you for everyone who
joined youtube and twitch and GameSpot
it was fun time I was fun good way to
start off go Friday
happy Friday weekend dry day yeah go
make up a bear a bear fighting ring
someone do that
Monster Hunter or Friday was tomorrow's
sorry later on today at 2:00 p.m. Ben
and John Luke's back this week he's not
at a wedding so he'll be back on Monster
Hunter Fridays so come back to twitch
dot TV slash game spot for that or at
our YouTube channel but thanks for
joining everybody later see you
[Music]
[Music]